hello berlin i am sonarpankish and my
talk deals with biases and language
model and data and its interpretability
so a little bit of background about
myself i work as a as an ai researcher
at sama technologies previously i have
worked as a software lead in an iit
madras incubated startup and before that
i also served as a visiting faculty in
robotics and computer vision these days
i am mostly working in the field of nlp
and its application in biodomain model
compression and fairness in ai and i am
so grateful for the organizers like
pycon ge and pi data berlin to give me
the opportunity to share some of the
insights so let's get started
so the topics we will be covering today
are
language model what is language model
what are the different kinds of language
model
transformers the building block of uh
of
you know
after new nlp the building block of
world etc
uh why is it important to check for
biases and language model
examples with open ai
and google translate
contextual and non-contextual language
model non-contextual language biasing
we will also see contextual language
model with this example of birth
we will see bird visualization the
biasing effort you will see importance
of interpretability tools
interpretability visualization and open
source library like 360 aix 360.
so the first question arises
what is uh
what is
what is language model
so a language model learns to predict
the probability of sequences of words so
example there is a sentence uh
tom is a bad cat and that
the language model is trying to predict
the probability distribution of each
word given uh the whole uh other sent
other words in the sentence there are
two typical kind of language models
statistical language model and neutral
uh language models so statistical
language models are traditional status
uses traditional statistical techniques
like
n grams hidden markov model and certain
language
linguistic rules to learn the
probability of the word distribution in
the sentence whereas in neutral language
model and these are the new players in
an alpha town that have said past
statistical model ineffectiveness and
they use different kind of neural net
networks to learn uh you know modern
language like your elmo your birth etc
uh then there is comes pre-trained
language models so
a lot of uh many tasks is nlp tasks are
very gpu intensive very you know
training intensive
so uh a good way to go through is to
train it first on a gpu and then do the
transfer learning and use it in
different cases uh like for example
hugging face has a lot of different kind
of more pre-trained models and you can
just take it off the shelf and use it
according to uh your uh
like suppose if you have to do document
uh classification you can uh use one of
the models trained uh
pre-trained on the language and then uh
you know uh
use it in your downstream task
so in the language model there are two
kind of language model one is auto
regression that predicting based on the
past words uh predicting new words based
on the past words so for example tom is
a bad
black so
regressive will use all the words used
before and then try to
generate a new word whereas if we see
auto encoding it will try to
predict the probability of the masked
word so for example tom is a mask cap so
it will try to predict is it good
bad dirty
uh etc etc based on its uh you know its
previous work and past words so it's
future words and passwords so it's both
it's bi-directional so if you see
different examples of free train model
there's bird there's open ai there's
elmo so bird uses bi-directional
transformer of
open air uses a left to right
transformer elmo uses the concatenation
of independently trained left to right
or
right to left celestine to generate
feature for down stringing tasks now if
you see downstream tasks these are the
ultimate tasks that you have to perform
like name entity recognition sequence
labeling uh documentation classification
etc etc
if you want to visualize how the pos
looks you can easily
visualize their embeddings using the
train models
using tsme a library
now come to an let's come to an
important point why is it in according
to study language models
uh why uh why are we so focused on uh
mitigating biases or de-biasing
so
the use of ai in sensitive areas
including hiring like criminal justice
health care provisioning or resource
allocation has
has steered a huge debate in the
community about biases and fairness
because if you can imagine uh our own
world is so biased our data is so biased
so
the models will try to predict the same
kind of biases that we have now because
our data is biased so ai has been
shaped by flawed data and full of
societal bias data where muslims are
considered more violent and females are
considered less smart for a job
so these
biases and data will not only be baked
in the models but it could all actually
enhance increase the intensity of biases
as well
and the issues algorithmic fairness is
one with the mass of societal
uh the allocation of welfare schemes
welfare resources to prioritize life
saving to surgeries and all these things
and job application all these epic all
these things are going to get uh be
based on ai and if we
uh let the data dirt the model
so
be able to mitigate it
so
uh one of the example is google uh
translation
so if we see uh if there was any there's
a tree by uh
there was a tweet where someone tried to
translate finnish which is a gender
neutral language uh which is a gender
neutral language to english and
the results was he's a journalist he's a
leader she is exhausted she has a
grandchild he works she has headache he
has a great car she is taking care of
the child he takes care of things so we
already see that he is being related to
journalists being a leader
and owning something where she is
related mostly to caregiving
and to uh having a headache
or you know uh taking care of the child
so uh we use these things in every day
like recommendation system and you know
for chargeboards etc
uh one more example could be in open air
playground so if you give a general
neutral uh
name like taylor loves her job she is a
great so it feels like she's a great
teacher she loves her job whereas if you
give it a
like
henry is a great at his profession and
he is a great so it comes out he's a
great doctor so we already see the model
are associating a female character more
with a teacher and a male character more
with a doctor
now after seeing all these examples you
will see what kind of language models
are there so the first and basic
language model comes as non-contextual
language models
uh which includes methods like skip
graham and
sibo and
uh so what is the meaning of
non-contextual method models so uh
non-protection models the meaning of a
word does not depend on what context it
is being used
so
apple and after products
maybe it could be used in different ways
but they their embedding will be same
same
so let's buy apple products
apple is healthy they both will have
same and their embeddings and the
context will not depend
uh the embedding will not depend on the
context
so
as we can see it will create a lot
because there are so many examples like
uh like run away from bear and bear
grylls uh i like their girls uh both
pair will be same and wedding so they
create kind of uh non-context scenarios
uh
on the other words present
like let's see the biasing technique and
how we
how we can do it in our contextual
methods how we can remove
how we can remove
biases using projection method
so first important method is the
projection technique in which original
embedding is projected onto a common
gender
axis
the results look something like this
where you can see uh
that teacher editor has been reduced so
uh what's happening is we are trying to
check both of your
your conform is like your preserved
gender
roles like king coin brother sister
whereas also taking in consider of
where stereotypical gender
uh roles like teacher editor doctor
nurse so if we try to check the teacher
needs
has been faded away the correlation has
faded away
and whereas in
your king and queen there is uh there is
still a correlation so it removes the
correlate the
heart association
with preservation of the general rules
if you want to create the embedding
and calculate the gender direction
project all the embedding away from the
sexes and plot the results
so the results will look like
something like this
so uh we can include the past great
works that have been done uh for removal
of biases
uh the first one
the first
work done was like
managed to computer programmer as
womanist homemaker by talk about this
game
where he created two kind of embeddings
and try to
see if they are like equal so study of
gender stereotypes word embedding also
deals with the d biasing with soft bias
correlate correction it provides a
method for modifying and embedding to
remove gender stereotypes such as
association between uh the word
receptionist and female by maintaining
desired association such as now uh there
was uh
there was another great work published
which says
uh
that
the projection method actually doesn't
work it's uh by
lipstick on a pig which says uh you are
actually hiding the gender biases
instead of removing uh the gender biases
yeah by
a projection method then a paper came
called uh measuring stereotypical biases
and pre-trained language model that used
with measuring uh the stereotypical
biases with different kind of scores
like cms score ls score
uh then came as
a
another projection method uh which was
removing information from neural
representation and the method is based
on repeated training of linear
classifier that predicts a certain
property we aim to remove that followed
by projection of representation on their
null spaces so uh there is just a
projection of all these undesired
characters of
displayed on gender and they are null
out by uh
biometrics
now let's discuss the contextual
language models uh the word embeddings
in which the context has been used like
here the apple product and apple
will have different embeddings example
bird and flare
in 2017 a paper called all you attention
is all you need and that led to the
transformer or that
led to the uh
like use of transformers and that
changed everything
and the reasons to change everything it
was easier to train
treatment model can be fine-tuned can be
trained on unsupervised text so you can
easily paralyze the text you can use the
transfer learn you can train the model
you
use the pre-trained model in your
downstream tasks
how is it able to do that so here is the
transformer model architecture you could
see
different encoder and decoder stack
that i can uh you can now segment it out
easily
which one is the encoder which one is
decoder and there's different kind of
input output processes
but the main attention
uh is happening over here like uh
there's a query key and then there's a
value so encoder decoder attention
between input sequence and output
sequence then there's self attention
there's multi-head attention
okay but basically what we want is to
take query and find the most similar key
pl k by doing dot product for q and k
and the closest query key product will
have the highest value followed by a
soft marks that will drive q dot k with
the smaller closest values
so with the softmax it will look
something like this
and then we find the most attention
over there
so
so we saw the architecture of
transformer and how it tries to uh you
know calculate attention to each of the
words like multi-headed attention models
uh with the help of my multi-attention
multi-headed attention holder and
self-potential models and and now bert
is the biggest example that makes use of
this transformer and attention mechanism
that learn contextual relations between
the words
like suppose tom is a bad cat so cat is
really it's kind of
has attention to both tom and too bad
okay because previously
uh
there was no mechanism by which one can
know that that is related to tom because
it was mostly related to being bad but
now you can have multi-headed attention
so tom a cat can be both tom
and cat can uh bad as well
uh here the position encoding sentence
and padding
token embedding you give you mask one of
the words and at the end you will get
the probability
of that masked word or your next
prediction models and uh so there are
two kind of birth models there is both a
mass language model and there is next
prediction model
if we see the visualization of attention
but
can see the designer is associating
itself more with keys
uh than her
and this is the biggest uh this is what
bias means right
uh that we're giving more uh weightage
or some some gender is giving more
contribution
to the designer than uh you know as the
other gender
so in that case you can use fine-tune
model how do we fine-tune
the model
so these codes are available uh i will
make them available on
my repo
and this is how you or you first try to
mask one of the
mask one of the words uh
one of the tokens and then you
kind of provide the predictions of this
output
and then uh soft access prediction find
the weightage and you get top five
weightage of that you know the top five
uh maximum weight of the predictive
tokens
okay
so the end results if you want to see it
will look something like this the lawyer
wanted to help the designer but
that could she
refuse so she will be masked and then
the masked token will be predicted so
here we can see it is trying to predict
key with the weight is of 0.4 and she
with the width of 0.16
right but when you fine tune that when
you find you uh your model uh
that is like you know making new kind of
association based on data so if you
provide it with a general neutral data
if the data set is gender neutral it
tries to
kind of
decrease that now if we can see the mass
prediction of him is reduced to 0.01
which is which is a lot of a lot of
progress so if you want to visualize
everything i had uh
i had this so bird is in red and green
is the fine-tuned verse so each of the
word is representing if each of the
point is uh on the x-axis is
representing different kind of
profession
and on the y uh axis uh the
the the distance between
his prediction
uh to the profession i mean he's to the
professional prediction so we can see
the the distance has reduced a lot
uh it's kind of like settling down
so at last if we investigate the
calculator bias model we find out that
the underlying data
is responsible for biased models
and
you know there there should be ways to
find out what kind of biases lie within
the data
and then there are many tools in
our
explainability and interpretability
tools are available like aif 360.
so biases and data can occur
because of sampling omission of certain
groups and exclusion and under
representation of certain group so
prejudice bias exclusion omission inside
we get from data of the model we have to
be very careful about uh how
conservative that bias is for example if
we see here in the probability grid
uh y-axis is a age group and excesses is
the uh gender group we see females are
much less in as at the pointers of alone
uh as compared to male 1
only 19 percent as compared to male
which is like 23
so uh
there could be numerous numerous reasons
for that maybe females are better at
managing
the credits or debt or
men have more burdens or maybe
that fema's are not getting as much as
credit
uh as uh male uh troops so there could
be numerous reasons which could not be
inferred from here
so visualization of data set is based on
privileged and under
underprivileged group biases will impact
protected feature that is privileged and
underprivileged group representation
there can be a lack of representation or
an over representation of the
underprivileged group the model will
learn either too much or too little
about the truth so the distribution is
uh centered around and uh it represented
around under primary school of could be
far away from that within this group as
an example we can see in recidivism what
happens there are two features
of confusion matrix that do feature of
risk prediction made by compass is it
and the ground truth so we see that uh
people who were you know uh
scene that they will uh they will uh
again do the crime uh much more in
african-american uh
uh
confusion matrix than conclu uh
confession confusion it's actually uh
totally opposite
so we
how do we quantify the data set so we
quantify the dataset based on your
statistical parity difference and
desperate impact they both have formulas
according to them which one of them is
the favorable group
now pre-processing of biases
pre-processing based on feature
engineering sometimes continuous
features capture bias because there are
so many sparse area where the model can
fill the void with assumption balancing
or resampling in the representation
problem can be fixed by balancing the
data set which is done by say library
xci library has a balanced function that
does this by down sampling and up
sampling of group representations some
tools called smooth or synthetic
minority over sampling technique or
leaving initialize it by specifying
grouped and fit the transform the data
as you would with any of the cyclical
encoder or
scalar
so there are in processing post
processing all focused on a balanced
classification and equalized odds for
privileged and misclassification
treatment performance investigation
so at last ai is going to be a big reset
in our society and it's on us and now if
we want to carry our current biases from
the date with the data
to the future or we want to make the
future a better place i'm available at
twitter all the materials will be
available uh on github under ikigai
groups
uh which is uh which i'm going to i'm
planning to open source where you can
all also contribute
about uh
the data set you can contribute unbiased
data set you can contribute
visualization tools you can uh
actually we are trying to make an
augmentation model based on these
unbiased data so ikigai is going to be
open sourced you can await it from
saunapankish95
you can any day connect on connect with
me on linkedin
and i will make everything uh
public
on twitter linkedin github etc
so thank you so much thank you so much
for your time
all right
okay um i think we have some questions
online um can you hear us
hey everyone yes perfect
okay um the first question comes from
james uh what do you think of the role
the size of the model plays in public uh
perpetuating buyers any thoughts on the
stochastic parrots paper
oh i if you could repeat the questions i
didn't get the question
what do you think of the role the size
of the model plays in perpetuating bias
and do you have any thoughts on the
stochastic parrots paper
so
the size of the model like depends on
the data set and the more data set is
like bias
so it all
it it's a round circle like the more
data is biased the more that uh even
heavier uh
models like bird are highly contributing
towards uh you know uh biases and models
so
uh it's all around circle the less
unbiased dataset we have like you know
we know bias data set you can search it
online it's called you know grade uh
which i have used for fine tuning uh so
that would be like uh better
just making data set better instead of
you know making the models heavier
it's better
okay um
second question is it better to use the
projection technique to remove bias or
to mask pronouns and retrain the model
so uh they were
totally different use like one was the d
biasing was for non-contextual uses like
globe
uh
globe is an embedding whereas masking
was for contextual language models like
bird so uh yeah so they have totally
different use uh non-contextual has a
lot more examples like you know fast
text globe
uh i could give you byte pair or
different you can search it like
non-contextual versus contextual so i
have covered both and how you can be
biased in both situations
yeah
all right
um i think that's all the question we
have online
let me check again yes so we can open it
up to
the audience here in the room
does anyone here have questions for our
speaker
um i don't see any raised hands if
you're raising your hand please shout
um okay
so
that was a short q a
i think
the second
talk should begin in
10 minutes here
and thank you again for your great
talk your great presentation and thank
you for answering these questions
um
yeah we would love to have you here in
berlin but
um
this was also great
yeah thank you bye